When it comes to Marvel trailers, every moment
has something important to say and comes with
the promise of deeper meanings, hidden explanations,
and misleading misdirections.
Let's break it down and take a look at more
details you may have missed in the newest
Avengers: Endgame trailer.
The new trailer featured a group of heroes
walking through the Avengers hangar.
If the scene from the trailer felt familiar,
there's a good reason for that: The Super
Bowl spot also ended on a quick tease of a
string of heroes walking through the same
hangar.
The thing is, each trailer seems to be showing
distinctly different groups of people at different
times.
The Big Game clip seemed to depict Cap, Thor,
Black Widow, Rocket, Ant-Man, War Machine,
and either Bruce Banner or Clint Barton.
They also appear to be wearing their normal
super-suits.
This time around the setting remained, but
the shot showed Cap, Ant-Man, Hawkeye, War
Machine, Black Widow, Iron Man AND Nebula
- all sporting new suits that look an awful
lot like a variation on Hank Pym's Quantum
Realm suit, or even the space armor that the
heroes donned in the cartoons.
What's going on here?
Why do we have two nearly identical shots
with completely different groups and suits?
"What do you think is happening right now?"
"It doesn't matter."
"It's good."
Whenever Endgame takes place, speculation
is running high that it will showcase a sizable
jump forward in time.
In the newest trailer we get a clip of Clint
Barton with what appears to be his family.
The next shot is a repeat from the last trailer,
showing a distressed Barton with a completely
different haircut.
Then there's Black Widow.
She ended Infinity War with short blonde hair,
but in the trailer she's shown with long hair
that drapes past her shoulders.
Her hair also goes from blonde to her natural
red, and that takes time to grow out.
Black Widow seems to be the big clue that
we are dealing with some sort of time jump
between movies.
The first trailer had a moment showing Steve
Rogers looking at a compass with Agent Peggy
Carter's picture in it, a touching reminder
of how far the man has come since he was a
scrawny kid desperately trying to fight for
his country.
Although apparently, it wasn't just a callback
to an emotional past, because Cap's old flame
can be heard in a voiceover during the new
trailer too.
The world has changed.
None of us can go back."
Sound familiar?
It's the same line she said as Cap sat by
her deathbed in Winter Soldier.
"The world has changed.
None of us can go back.
All we can do is our best
And sometimes the best we can do is to start
over."
Whatever the implications might be, the appearance
of Peggy in the new trailer is starting to
make us wonder how she might fit into the
bigger picture.
The slo-mo walk through the HQ hangar was
dripping with teasers, but the new suits and
appearance of Tony Stark and Nebula made it
easy to miss one of the biggest questions
that the scene posed: where were Bruce Banner,
Thor, and Carol Danvers?
We now know thanks to that last tag at the
end of the new trailer along with the mid-credits
scene from her own movie that Danvers will
be joining up with the team, which makes her
absence from the hangar scene that much more
conspicuous.
Does the scene take place before she arrives?
The absence of both Banner and Thor is even
more puzzling.
Both should be around from the beginning of
the film, as they were among the survivors
of the snap.
We're still waiting for the three-movie arc
for Hulk that Mark Ruffalo's spoken about,
so Hulk's almost guaranteed to be in the movie
somewhere.
What about Thor?
Asgard is destroyed and he has Stormbreaker,
so there's little need to be off elsewhere
on his own personal errands at this point.
Why are the three most powerful members of
the team not present?
It seems like a bit of a handicap if the group
is going up against Thanos.
Another intriguing detail is easy to miss
during that hangar walk, and it has to do
with an Avenger that typically doesn't get
much screen time: Rhodey.
Always playing the number two to Tony, Rhodey
was nevertheless a solid presence throughout
Infinity War, doing everything he could to
help keep the enemy contained on the battlefield
of Wakanda.
In fact, it seemed a shame that it was the
sheepish Banner that ended up donning that
Hulkbuster armor when the much more experienced
Iron Patriot was standing by.
Fans have been looking for a War Machine decked
out in Hulkbuster armor ever since spotting
a Hulkbuster War Machine Lego set planned
for Endgame.
While it doesn't come across as quite Hulkbuster
size, the armor Rhodey is wearing in the clip
is undeniably a bit beefier than normal.
Whether the team is heading into the Quantum
Realm or space, it makes sense that Rhodey
would want a little bit more protection.
Or maybe he just wanted more room to pack
weapons in.
"I think I'll take it."
"Which one?"
"All of it."
The theme of the first trailer tended to revolve
around loss.
Not so with the second.
This time the whole message can be boiled
down to three words: "Whatever it takes."
"Whatever it takes."
As the group is shown in various capacities
preparing to do "whatever it takes," though,
there are four people that stand out from
the crowd.
First to say the line is Cap, followed by
Clint, then Natasha, then, finally, Tony Stark.
"Whatever it takes."
While the mantra seems like a good one for
the film, the question is, why do these four
say it?
Both Chris Evans and Robert Downey Jr. have
been rumored to be approaching the end of
their time in the MCU, but the thought that
four of the original six Avengers are ready
to do "whatever it takes" could imply a larger
culling than anyone was expecting.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.